vraiment dans une micro zone où en fait
là on est vraiment dans une région de
bocage geneviève de braquer la
présidente régionale de la coordination
rurale et son plus proche voisin
françois est également agriculteurs les
deux exploitations sont distantes d'à
peine 4 km mais sont foncièrement
différente chez françois en étant
champagne berrichonne une plaine
céréalière aux terres fertiles en est
quand même dans la dans les collines et
les vallons chez geneviève la terre
colle aux pieds des chevaux seul l'herbe
pousse sur ses vallons sa ferme est
pourtant classée elle aussi en champagne
berrichonne sans en tirer aucun avantage
une zone comme la mienne c'est zéro
revenus on ne peut plus tirer de revenus
et je dirais aujourd'hui c'est si
l'agriculture veut continuer d'exister
en france et dans des zones comme les
miennes il va falloir parler revenus il
va falloir qu'on nous aide
il va falloir qu'on nous aide à garder
ce qu'on a parce que le biotope qui a
créé mon père ici ça là le paysage qu'on
a gardé qu'on a sauvegardé va falloir
nous aider aujourd'hui la politique
agricole commune ne vient pas au secours
de tous ces territoires
ici on a même supprimé l'indemnité
compensatoire de handicap naturel car
l'europe a imposé à la france un maximum
de 10% des terres agricoles éligibles à
ce dispositif
mes garçons c'est d'ailleurs ce que j'ai
des garçons pour geneviève est en
général au sein de la coordination
rurale
la nouvelle réforme de la pac est vue
avec méfiance l'affichage
environnemental de ce texte laisse
craindre de nouveaux soucis on peut se
tourner vers le bio effectivement parce
qu'ils vont aider le bio ils ont été
achevés 3 h 23 haute valeur
environnementale de niveau 3 on peut se
classer achevée trois mois je vais faire
la démarche certainement mais je dire
qu'est ce que ça va me rapporter rien ça
va pas me dégager de revenus de toute
façon aujourd'hui 50 % des agriculteurs
qui gagne pas le smic les 50 % des
agriculteurs qui avons plus de plus de
50 ans donc en fait inévitablement il va
falloir modifier les choses s'ils
veulent garder une agriculture pour la
coordination rurale
l'administration européenne a abandonné
la notion de spécificités des
territoires
le syndicat compte plutôt sur la france
et peut-être même sur les conseils
régionaux
pour remettre un peu d'équité dans les
soutiens financiers après la mise en
place de la future pac